tim pedneault jobin et maire de gatineau
il est notre invité ce soir monsieur
pedneault jobin bonsoir bonsoir jeu
vidéo est ce que vous partager le point
de vue du premier ministre le go sur le
fait que la pcu pour les étudiants
pourraient d inciter au travail
mais l étape actuelle c'est que de
l'inquiétude d'ombré les vannes pour
embaucher c'est là où on veut savoir si
concrètement c'est une
c'est un problème mais on sait déjà pour
les quinze jours ça va être difficile
avec les mêmes ressources on va voir on
voir pour accueillir la moitié moins
d'enfants etc ça risque d'être difficile
pour bien des familles
si le gouvernement doit s'en mêler pour
moi c'est assez priorité les camps de
jour de l'été bon on l'a on parle de
pertes de plus en plus important tant
pour pour les municipalités des pertes
de 800 901 millions 1 milliard de
dollars pour les municipalités en raison
de la coved 19
quand on regarde seulement 2020 pour le
transport collectif on parle de 670
millions de paires c'est quoi la
situation des municipalités en ce moment
la situation est difficile parce que
l'élément le plus important c'est les
pertes de revenus mais il ya aussi des
dépenses qui augmentent le nos policiers
quand il faisait des points de contrôle
nous juste nous autres c'est 400 à 1000
$ de temps supplémentaire sans adopter
on a acheter de l'équipement on en a
prêté en fait don à nos données au
réseau de la santé on a transformé des
arénas refuges pour itinérants donc les
les dépenses des villes ont augmenté
aussi grâce à l'accueil à cause à kovy a
remis les revenus s'effondrent juste en
transport en prenant ses 670 millions
vous l'avez dit de de manque à gagner
cette année seulement nous et 3.6
millions par mois qu'on perd parce que
les revenus sont pas là les autobus sont
vides
ce fait que c'est extrêmement difficile
sur le milliard 1.2 milliard d'estimé de
pertes pour les villes cette année 60 %
ces transports encore ouais c'est quand
même énorme
c'est beaucoup pour une situation
fiscale qui particulière pour les
municipalités
là on va en parler dans un instant mais
les gouvernements laissent entendre
qu'il pourrait aider les municipalités
le québec notamment aujourd'hui à quoi
devrait
ambler une aide aux municipalités selon
vous pour moi c'est vraiment une aide en
lien avec les pertes de revenus quand on
subit présentement chez chopin était
rencontre avec le ministre mende et
renaît bonnardel de when they qu
aujourd'hui puisqu'on lui disais c'est
il faut compenser les pertes de revenus
des sociétés transport en commun parce
que sinon on va couper dans les services
à un moment où le service est encore
nécessaire parce que les gens vont avoir
moins d'argent pour se payer une auto
episodes je mets de côté les enjeux
d'environnement donc on veut pas se
permettre de recruter de reculer pardon
en transport en commun avec l'aide
devrait de l'aide
info pour le transport en commun ou
siens font carrément pour nous aider à
équilibrer leur budget cette année parce
que vous n'avez pas le droit de faire de
déficit on n'a pas le droit de faire des
déficits et nos marges de manoeuvre
c'est soit on coupe dans les services
est en situation de crise économique on
ne peut pas faire ça surtout que des
villes souvent on offre les seuls
services qui sont abordables sinon
carrément gratuit ou augmenter les taxes
qu'on voudrait pas faire non plus dans
une situation de crise économique
alors si on n'a pas des dents se
retrouvent enfin en fait faire partie du
problème plutôt que faire partie de la
solution mais est ce que c'est ça donc
la solution éventuellement d'augmenter
les taxes foncières aux citoyens moi je
pense que non moi je pense que ça prend
de l'aide des gouvernements pour éviter
de faire sortir la meilleure
illustration de notre difficulté fiscale
c'est quand les choses vont se met à
aller bien
le fédéral et le provincial vont avoir
l'impôt sur le revenu l'impôt sur les
entreprises qui vont se remettre a
généré beaucoup d'argent la taxe à la
consommation à tps et tvq et avec ceux
ou incapables de se rembourser
nous on est encore pris avec les deux
mêmes options on coupe dans les services
où on augmente la taxe foncière parce
qu'on n'a pas d'autre marge de manoeuvre
fiscale l'économisme a bien roulé ça
prend pas mal d'édifices avant d'avoir
une vraiment différence dans le budget
municipal
pour sûr du point de vue de l'intérêt du
contribuable
c'est que les gouvernements qui ont des
marges de manoeuvre on ne peut nous
arriver parce que les taxes foncières
ckoi 70% des revenus à peu près là en
moyenne des municipalités en moyenne
on prend les en lieu de taxes donc ce
choeur à québec qui entrevoit payent
pour leur propre édifice est encore plus
élevé que ça gatineau sera 86% de
dépendance à la taxe foncière etc nous
ressemble
quand je vous disais ça bouge pour donc
si on n'a pas d'oeil
donc ça prend ça prend de l'aide
ponctuelle messieurs pedneault jobin
dites vous mais est-ce que vous relancer
votre demande pour une réforme complète
de la fiscalité des municipalités que
vous réclamez quand même depuis
longtemps
ah oui pis si nous la gatineau ça fait
quatre reprises en quatre ans on gère
tornades inondations qu'ovide avec la
taxe foncière ça aucun sens qu'on vient
d'ouvrir un aréna pour accueillir des
immigrants nous nos taxes lente et or il
s'est fait pourrait que du dégoût
asphalt depuis un petit peu de
bibliothèques cc pour conçu pour pour
être un gouvernement de proximité alors
qu'on agit et c'est bon pour tout le
monde donc on agisse comme un
gouvernement de proximité parce que
soient les mieux placés pour agir mais
notre fiscalité suis pas il faut
absolument qu'on transforme sur pied il
ya même des effets un peu pervers à la
taxe foncière
quand on augmente les taxes le s'il
s'est pas basée sur le revenu de la
personne et la taille de la maison donc
dans un semi détaché en retraités de la
fonction publique et le même montant de
theix qu'une une mère de famille
monoparentale cessa pas de sens de faire
pays à des gens qui n'ont pas le revenu
adéquat des dépenses pour gérer des
grills il faudrait que ça vienne d'un
impôt sur le revenu ou d'une taxe à la
consommation mais quelque chose qui qui
attaquent pas les plus sûres qui ont les
revenus les plus beaux mais ce discours
là que vous teniez spa première fois
puis la hongrie entendant en pleine
crise financière dans un contexte qui
différent mais ce qu'ils aient entendu
est-ce que ça chemine ça cette réforme
fiscale a tellement et je dirais que le
gouvernement le goût nous avons fait un
pas en avant pour un pas en arrière un
pas en avant on ne donne nous a donné
une partie de la croissance date et
véhicules moi j'espère un des beaux
moments de ma carrière car gouvernement
fait ça un an après ils nous forcent à
payer pour les terrains du ministère
d'éducation l'a donc des écoles ski ski
et qui campent et notre problème
d'infrastructures donc pour moi il ya
des choses qui qu'ils pensent mais qui
passe pour
complet donc la bataille est loin d'être
finie mais les crises nous donne une
occasion de le redis je regarde mon rien
la 500 millions père titane et là ils
peuvent pas payer ça avec la taxe
foncière
c'est dans l'intérêt de personne de
faire ça surtout quand on parle de
personnes âgées par exemple qui
voudraient rester à la maison
dans une maison modeste ou qui sont
capables de se payer mais les taxes
foncières finissent par les force à
quitter leurs maisons parce qu'on veut
donc ça vous prend un rendez-vous une
espèce de point de bascule avec le
gouvernement du québec au cours des
prochaines semaines pour être capable de
modifier cela oui au moins
d'entreprendre d'abord ça prend de
l'aide à court terme et aussi
entreprendre c'est chaud là sur une
réforme fiscale en profondeur
j'espère que c'est une des retombées
positives savoir-être sur la remise en
question de la fiscalité municipale
maxime pedneaud-jobin maire de gatineau
merci merci beaucoup